Google's Picassa is a free software
application for sharing organizing and
editing digital photos and
videos our videos are often about cloud
computing applications but Picassa isn't
completely tied to a browser it's
actually free software you can download
a free copy of Picassa from its official
website the Picassa setup file is just
under 10 Meg
[Music]
right after installation when you launch
Picassa for the first time it'll ask you
whether you want Picassa to scan your
entire computer for pictures or only the
my documents my pictures and desktop
folders to import your pictures into
Picassa select an appropriate option and
click on
continue next Picassa will ask whether
you want to use Picassa photo viewer as
the default viewer for common image file
types
[Music]
the interface of Picassa is really
simple the left side shows the folders
which contain the imported images the
main body shows all the imported images
and videos in thumbnail View and at the
bottom of the window you can see several
options to upload email print
Etc though Picassa is not a heavyduty
photo editing application like Adobe
Photoshop it still offers a wide variety
of editing options which are really
useful
[Music]
to edit any picture double click on the
image you want to
edit on the left side you'll see plenty
of Options under three tabs to edit the
selected
picture the basic fixes tab allows you
to crop straighten and add text to
images other options include Auto
contrast Auto color and
retouch the I'm feeling lucky option is
a quick fix to automatically fix common
problems with
photos the fine tune button allows you
to tune your photos using these
sliders the effects tab includes options
such as sharpen sepia black and white
wary film grain saturation and many
others
[Music]
you can share your photos with people by
uploading Picassa web albums and then
inviting viewers to use this feature you
need a Gmail email
[Music]
account if you edit photos which have
already been uploaded to a Picassa web
album Picassa 3 offers a sync to web
option to let you keep your online
photos updated with your most recent
Picassa edits folders or albums that
have this option enabled will mirror any
edits immediately in your online Picassa
web
[Music]
album if sharing an album seems a bit
boring watch out Picassa allows you to
combine all your photos and videos with
background music to create a movie file
and then put it on YouTube
Picassa 3 has plenty of excellent
editing and sharing
features it has a smooth graphical
interface and features great integration
with Picassa web albums YouTube and blog
spot if you don't need a heavyduty photo
editing application and just want to
manage edit and share photos Google's
Picassa is a good solution for you
[Music]